stando attenti ragazzi benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti jlg seggi ci
siamo sudditi infiniti 3.0 cioè un video
fatti in collaborazione con disney e
talaltro ringrazio moltissimo anche di
sting per la possibilità di miliardi sì
però stai calmo che sto parlando è che
possiamo cominciare anche perché non
devo capire un attimino come si gioca
l'altro ragazzi c'è una cosa che mi
hanno dato che è questa praticamente se
tu infili personaggi qua sopra compaiono
nel gioco nuovo tipo magia o cose del
genere
no ragazzi allora sempre chi non
conoscesse star wars anakin se la tira
sempre sì però non è che devi fare super
e allora se è meglio technic ragazzi
prima di cominciare voleva che vi che
non sapendo i comandi cosa fa ma ragazzi
ho capito che posso lanciare le casse
premix per saltare grazie grazie non lo
sapevo questo non è proprio se non me lo
dicevi non ci arrivava così che se
giorgio sì però staccato è sparita la
causa va beh sì beh ragazzi velati posso
farli fuori o cose
scusa frate ragazzi io combatto
attestate è una cosa guarda al ralenti
proprio che manco il matrix la ragazza è
importante non è questo l'importante è
saper che fa sì vabbè c'è ovviamente no
ma le chiavi le potresti anche usare la
forza lo zar a forza oddio no vabbè se è
certo lui usa la forza per spostare
questa cosa dio non riuscì usa la forza
manco per spostare i compiti in classe
una diversità di punti di vista
fai vedere che se usarlo scherzi a posto
che la forza sia con me è il taxi e taxi
adesso
che taglio di capelli da figo frate a
posto
scontro epico in arrivo devono fare io è
finito così a bello chewbecca su vecchia
il mio preferito in assoluto nella vita
di star wars fatemi usa voglio usare il
suo vecchio come si usa su becca subito
lo voglio cioè tanti ragazzi io ho fa vj
non sa manco la patente per la macchina
però so guidare astronavi piegandomi
così come me che fare con scappare si
sta abbassando
scappata
si sa che corri nello spazio che esplori
centro della mente le storie possono
essere uniche come chi le condivide
gioie rabbia hanno rimandato quindi a
caso siamo passati da da star wars a
inside out
adesso comando quelli linz va beh ho
preso rabbia attenzione florenzi si
allunga il pallone florenzi il tiro ed è
gol
dal centrocampo teoria l'abbia dopo sta
cosa dovrebbe mangiarmi vivo e sano che
non sa se ha preso a ecco l'aver mi
servì sembrava strano personaggio di
smith o eccolo lo posso fare veramente i
personaggi cio tipo yoga credo che io lo
devo ammettere qui i ragazzi non so
perché c'è questo presentimento ma mi
spunta yoda dal uno schema beh va beh
questa la tavola magica regalateci
piazza un hamburger entra pure
l'hamburger
perfetto ragazzi siamo sul crepuscolo
della repubblica che uno dei play set di
infiniti tra l'altro è qua e la partenza
classica di star wars e va bene devo
provare usare yoda per vedere se è il
mio idolo è il mio idolo in assoluto
peccato che non c'è il su beckham se ci
fosse stato lui avrei usato solo lui ma
comunque yoda mi soddisfa quindi va bene
anche lui comunque il loro di pubblico
si sia mai detto nessuno che hai un bel
naso appello del sì ma sai chi sono io
no no no no no stavo scherzando
importante che non credono di essere più
forti di me poi va bene va bene tutto
questo al lago
mi aspetto cosa ho schivato che cosa ho
schivato per questo preciso del rubicone
si devono realizzare in trovargli va
bene ma io non posso usare la forza per
farlo
tieni premuto cerchio per deflettere mi
porti su e poi mi lasci cadere
ciao ragazzi ciao frate già frate non è
caduto gianfrate perfetto laddove il
precipizio devi andare giù fra per bravo
che sotto quali anche un picco tra
bogino talmente forte da non usare
neanche neanche la spada proprio solo la
forza e sono troppo forza scusa
questo non è un parcheggio in sostanza è
veramente devastante come se non va come
se non fosse abbastanza un figo e lui
mister naso bello e quale parlavo prima
per il proprio veicolo più di tutto per
potrebbe se la fendi turno con il loro
sono tipi di scolo strade 12 giri move e
repressiva bene ed io sono un nano di
alto 50 centimetri cosa devo che più
alto ping ping fini premuto quadrato mi
ero dimenticato ragazzi che è che io
posso spostare anche i compiti in classe
con tutto sto casino perché non si alza
al ponte e non poteva alzare il ponte
con la forza
cosi sui muri cer ma ci mancherebbe
altro io faccio jogging tu corri sui
muri usa il pulsante per alzare il ponte
quale pulsante no perché se lo facevate
un po più grosso non lo vedevo grazie
mille ma sono riuscito a mancarlo
ragazzo effetto perfetto avrei potuto
usare la forza per farmi da rai due rai
dove vai
non posso buttare giù i miei alleati che
sfiga stai hackerando la porta senti e
anonymous vedi via gherardi meno qua
12345 c'ero io non so cosa mi è andata a
fare la spalla regala cosa ma è andata a
fare forse questi non li butto giù come
ragazzi e calmi e stavo scherzando
non butto giù anche questa è una guarda
come sei stato addestrato metà addio
l'input su col soffiandogli in faccia
che c'è un drago che che porta cos'è lo
prenderò ormai impossibile preso ho
capito 1 1 su 100 ci ho messo un'ora per
prenderne uno vabbè realtà e noi due
bravo
vedo che digiti molto velocemente chissà
che i siti frequenti lo corpo produce
all interno dello capito alla fabbrica
dei tredici ragazzi devono distruggere
la fabbrica questa è questo era
l'obiettivo all'inizio solo che io
spadaccia vaud che è cosa troppo bella
ho fatto come son passato comunque
ridendo e scherzando gli ho da si fa
anche la pertica e non riesco a fare
neanche un centimetro sulla perdita
ragazzi che guardano lo schiaccia la
loro schiaccia non ci credo o dire orso
stato e scusa frate non volevano giuro
ciao zio dietro non c'è niente stai
attento non c'è niente va beh io ci ho
provato
ciao fratello ciao e stato bello
conoscervi e noto ancora vivo ma come
avati si è suicidata avere di che ha
completato lui lato perché ha
giustamente capito io sono più forte chi
è spirito nuovo per ragazzi lo so e non
lo voglio rifare come si fa lo voglio
rifare subito io passerò la giornata
così ragazza ma chi è che ha inventato i
camion come mezzi di trasporto quando
c'e yoda che porta coi piedi una cassa
quattro volte lui mentre skate o dai
mamma mia quanto ore di combattimento
per battere si no ce l'ho fatta bravo
ragazzo il dominio
se fossi in te mi preoccuperei di più
dei jet generale greetings il nome della
repubblica ecco le eco rino alla viola
tutto fiero devo battere questo diverse
zone di rottame
e vabbé ma la mia pro agile stavo
scherzando è un nuovo tipo di frullatore
2.0 bravo bravo bravo prefetto ti diedi
con una spaccata s'è preso male mista da
quando gli ha detto sarò matto mi toglie
regala mi toglie esageratamente troppo
per essere un cyborg di eva lei la vera
però vedo almeno col tempo migliori che
ha il proprio palestra fratelli far
vedere i bicipiti complimenti bravo
molto bravo
adesso frulli la frutta con la metà del
tempo ecco le avevo detto che frullava
la frutta nella metà del tempo
dai dai dai dai dai o no così ho vinto
io
mamma mia cosa ho fatto cosa ho fatto
via via via via via subito prima che gli
manca niente morto ma non ci credo mai
belle è morta non è morto
adesso non ammazza vicinio domani dai
non ci credo mi ha ucciso luana kymco a
pensarci tu mi ha battuto yoda arriva
uno schiaffo e guarda è morto da solo
morte del soul have band non è morto
anche l'umore continua a non morire o
tre ore li combatte bravo ti ho fatto
male al polmone sinistro destro scuse
non si distingue la sinistra adesso sono
prigioniero
io voglio le frasi di hodan ei baci
perugina ragazzi che bello fermato la
fabbrica ragazzi ce l'ho fatta missione
compiuta dai ragazzi con coro episodio
spero che video vi sia piaciuto anno mi
piace per yoda che è morto poverino però
ha fatto la sua nana figura come al
solito ragazzi servito è piaciuto è
stato quanto è un mi piace anche
appoggiati facebook e come invitato la
descrizione scorsi discrete lì ci
vediamo al prossimo vinto della lega